okay so Alice in Borderlands season 2
ends on a big Cliffhanger with us
getting focused on a major card if you
read the Manga that the series is based
on then you'll know that this actually
holds a lot of significance not only
does it explain who really runs the game
but it also basically tells us to why
the entire thing was set up in the first
place throughout this video I want to go
through what the Joker card is how it
can close up the season and how it can
be used to set up a season 3 if they
decide to go that route if you enjoy the
video please hit the thumbs up button
and don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns like this every day without
the way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into Alison Borderland now in
order to talk about the card itself we
first have to talk about what the
Borderland is in the finale we discover
that Tokyo was actually hit by a
meteorite and that this had a massive
impact explosion that destroyed the
entire city several people were killed
during this and in the source material
we discovered that chunks from the media
actually came up and hit people this is
what sent them into the alternate world
no here they just simplified make it so
that it's one big event this was
obviously a massive loss of life over a
seemingly random occurrence this is
where the gioka comes into it first
introduced in chapter 63 this is
fittingly called Joker though we don't
learn too much about him as he only
appears for a couple of pages the reason
of there to piece together exactly what
he is now he appears right after the
queen is killed like what we see in the
show this happens after the croquet game
which is beautifully recaptured in the
series the fireworks go off and then all
the players are given the choice to
return to the real world or they can
remain behind in Borderland and go
through the games once more at this
point arisu sits down at the Queen's
table and he sees a dark figure saying
opposite him there's a joker card in
front and the pair have a conversation
that sort of reveals a lot of things
arisu asks who he is and he assumes that
he's the ruler over all of Borderland
The Joker replies by saying do I look
like a devil or do I look like a guy God
and the following page has one quick
panel that pretty much reveals
everything though you do kind of have to
piece it together in it we see a very
minute scoring people through a river
and on the shore we can see the crappy
looking humans and also skulls
surrounding the bottom of the panel this
is the Joker and this is also metaphor
for what Borderland is Greek mythology
used to tell us about the fireman coron
which I always pronounced wrong so
apologies for that now this was a figure
that would take the dead across the
river Stakes any transport damsels
between the land of the living and Hades
people were even buried with money in
their eyes so that they could pay him
and he's seen as someone who basically
rules of this state between life and
death and that's basically what's going
on in the show and Borderland itself is
a game set up by him and among other
meteorite killed hundreds of thousands
of people and the Joker saw this as
being a colossal waste of life he
thought this was unfair especially
because so many of those that died were
young kids who were yet to really get
the chance to do anything thing with
their lives so in order to give everyone
a chance he set up the game so that
players could battle it out for the
right to return back to the land of the
living the entirety of Borderlands is
basically a limbo between the living
world and death where victims of the
media strike have been assembled so they
can get the chance to live once more
this Borderland is literally a border
land between the two stages where Souls
of those are gathered for the games now
Caron Karen or whatever wanted people to
be sort of in a situation that they were
comfortable with and this is why
Borderland also looks like Tokyo if say
the media had struck Constantinople or
some I don't know why that was the first
place I came to mind we'll say ROM we'll
say ancient Rome if the media had struck
ancient Rome then players brought into
it would have seen that rather than
seeing the futuristic city of Tokyo that
would have blown their minds even
without the loss so it's basically a
recreation of their world so that they
can at least have some attachment to
their home and also what they're
fighting for so the games play out and
and the best players emerge out on top
now it's also important to bear in mind
that time moves differently in
Borderland and a minute in the real
world is months down there there are
also characters that arrive before
others and several Cycles which allow
citizens to be put in place for example
the face card holders that we see in the
game all arrived months and months
before the characters that we get behind
in the manga we discover that kiyuma
arrived there five months before arisu
and this is because the media struck
where he was at first he technically
died before arisu did and no the
explosion would have been about a second
difference between the pair the time
dilation meant that he arrived months
before in Borderland this allowed him
and the others to play through their own
cycle of games and when they won they
were given the choice to either return
back to the surface or to remain behind
those that chose to go back survived the
blast and they would have likely have
been found by the rescue crews those
that chose to stay were given the
position of being face cards and
citizens and they then play the games
against the next lot of players there
were lots of players that just didn't
want to go home because they either had
miserable lives or because they
preferred the rules of the game and the
time in between these people probably
would have been killed eventually and
they'd end up turning into the Land of
the Dead possibly a scored by The Joker
so that's the basic explanation of in
the source material with this being
something that's hinted towards in the
finale now the Joker card at the end
could have a number of different
meanings the first one is that it's just
a not at the ending of the manga and
it's used to show us what's going on a
lot of people who haven't read it are
probably confused but I kind of see this
as being a tease to who was behind it
all and also being like go and read the
Manga go [ __ ] read it if that's the
case and it closes out the series and
that's it the characters made it out and
the Joker oversaw this and left behind
his calling card to let us know what's
really happening the manga ends at this
place too and it's possible they don't
really want to go beyond this because
they've ran out of bookstorey at this
point Game of Thrones showed us what
happens when you let showriders come up
with their own ideas and they might just
not want to touch it Beyond this point
in this story however it might also be a
case of them teasing what's to come and
they might just say [ __ ] it let's tell
the story beyond the books because we've
got got great ideas and it never goes
wrong and the finale did leave some
things out such as arisu going off to
college and we had 731 days of rest to
Chisholm pass between the media strike
and the ending so plenty of time for
other games and the Joker itself could
represent a number of things going on
firstly The Joker is a wild card and the
figure is often thought of as being a
trickster therefore this entire ending
could be a trick and they may still be
stuck in the game Borderlands of course
looks identical to Tokyo and they could
pull a rug out from under our feet Joker
is still the last car that they need to
beat and they might have just ended a
new cycle like what they did at the end
of season one I kind of hope that's not
the case because then if they beat it it
could really be like well how do you
know this also isn't a trick there's
also their loss of memory too which is
in the manga as well well they have
their memories of borderline remove so
they can't be like here's what happens
when you die mate Upon returning to the
surface now if they do decide to do a
third season I think they will most
likely go that route with Joker being
revealed as the boss that's pulled the
wool over everyone's eyes they can also
show the games to explore their memories
of Borderland and possibly bring them
back the Bucks did talk about how they
could re-axis them with a certain key
but whether they go that route or not
remains to be seen anyway that's
everything you need to know about the
mysterious ending and also the Joker
card honestly I kind of helped the end
at this point because I think both
series were perfect adaptations and I
don't know if another one would spoil it
obviously that's my opinion and there
may be some of you who can't wait to get
back if you do get a third season I
don't think it'll take as long to
develop as this one due to the pandemic
holding that one back so yeah lots of
things that could happen my throat's a
bit destroyed as you can hear got a cold
uh but yeah drop a comment below and the
thumbs Up's appreciated for that reason
because I'm working when I'm not very
well then you you know you've got to
support me you got to support those
thumbs UPS now if you if you do that
then uh you'll be entered into a
competition where we're giving away Dawn
of the Dead and Black Adam to three
subscribers on the 15th of January all
you have to do yeah drop a like
subscribe with notifications on and also
leave a comment with your thoughts on
the series we picked them at random on
the 15th and the winners of the last one
on screen right now so that's you then
message me on Twitter at heavy spoilers
if you want something else to watch make
sure you check out Brighton of the
Season which will be linked on the
screen right now we talk about the
ending the games the characters lots of
stuff filled in uh so definitely head
over there right after this by the way
thanks for sticking through the video
I've been Paul I'll see you next time
take care peace